gold is the strongest asset of all time
not only has it been in use for
millennia but it serves as a phenomenal
store of value
and protection against market downturns
in history class
we've all heard about the time that
alcohol was banned in the time that
cuban cigars were banned
but did you know about the time that
gold was banned banning something that's
been so fundamental and integral to our
civilization for thousands of years
seems inconceivable but this is
precisely what the us government did for
41 years straight
between 1933 and 1974.
so here's a story of the time the u.s
banned gold
it all started in the 1920s when
everything seemed to be doing great
world war one had just come to a close
and it seemed that the us was heading
into a time filled with growth
prosperity and peace but unfortunately
a side effect that often accompanies
good times is complacency
people were complacent financial
institutions were complacent
and the government was complacent this
led to investors massively bidding up
stocks and speculation
banks lending out way more than they can
afford and the government just letting
it all happen
because of this the roaring 20s would
eventually end with a bang
as the us headed into the great
depression one of the first things
people do during an economic downturn
is reduce risk and pay off debt so it's
not surprising that people wanted to
withdraw their money from banks
and either turn it into gold or pay off
their outstanding debt
but as we previously discussed banks
were lending out way more money than
they could afford
so when everyone tried to withdraw their
money at the same time
many banks would go bankrupt in fact by
nearly half of all the banks in america
had failed meanwhile
the u.s government was watching the
entire crisis unfold but they couldn't
really do very much about it
in modern times whether that be the
dot-com bubble the 2008 financial crisis
or the pandemic
the federal reserve is quick to cut
rates and pump out stimulus
the federal reserve was established in
1913 so
it was around during the great
depression but at the time
they couldn't just go out and print
trillions of dollars like they do today
you see the dollar was backed by gold
meaning that the government had to hold
a specific amount of gold for every
dollar in circulation
ideally this number would be 100 meaning
that every single dollar was backed by
gold
however this would give the government
very little flexibility
so the number was actually 40 meaning
that 40
of the dollars in circulation were
backed by gold this was designed to
prevent the government from printing way
too much money
and ensured that each dollar was at
least somewhat backed up by a real asset
during the great depression though
people who still had money were hoarding
gold in order to protect the little
money they still had
this made it extremely hard for the
government to acquire gold and start
printing money to stimulate the economy
it should be noted though that this
didn't necessarily stop them from
printing money
anyway they did go under the 40
requirement
and this led to a larger and larger
disparity between how much gold the
government had
and how much money was in circulation
and people weren't oblivious to this
this was actually one of the primary
reasons millions were trading in all of
their cash for gold
these dynamics created a super unique
situation the government needed gold to
stimulate the economy
while people had to let go of their goal
to start spending dollars again and
constantly stimulate the economy
so from a macroeconomic view the
solution to stimulate the economy was
extremely clear
just transfer all the gold from the
people to the government
to accomplish this president roosevelt
issued proclamation 2039
which introduced a national bank holiday
in march of 1933
for four full days americans were
completely cut off from their access to
banking
americans were not allowed to trade in
their cash for gold or silver
and the banks were not allowed to export
any of their gold no withdrawals
deposits transfers or loans can be made
either
basically the entire banking system was
shut down to prevent more banks from
failing
during the closure congress would get
together and pass the emergency banking
act of 1933
this legislation called for examiners to
analyze the financial situation
of each bank and allow for a reopening
of the bank if it was found to be
financially secure
the legislation also allowed the federal
reserve to print more money
and send it to the banks to improve
liquidity president roosevelt would
famously say
i can assure you my friends that it is
safer to keep your money in a reopened
bank
than it is to keep it under the mattress
fortunately
people would trust them and once these
banks reopened people would indeed
deposit their cash
into these banks this act was successful
in averting a short-term crisis
but the underlying issue was still very
much present so
on april 5th 1933 president roosevelt
would come out with executive order 6102
aka the gold band all u.s citizens were
required to deliver all of their gold
coins
gold bullions and gold certificates
worth an excess of 100
to the federal reserve by may 1st in
return the federal reserve would pay
them 20
and 67 cents per ounce if people hung
onto their gold and the authorities
found out
they could be put in prison for up to 10
years and or find 10 000
or about 167 000 today
you might be thinking that this itself
is outrageously unfair
but just wait until you hear what
happened next in january of 1934
after the majority of the gold was
collected the department of treasury
would change the price of gold from 20
and 67 cents 35 dollars per ounce so
the government basically forced the
people to give up all their gold for a
cheap price
and once they collected all the gold
they jacked up the price
this is of course extremely unfair to
the people who held gold
but it seemed like it was the best
decision for the country as a whole
former gold owners were understandably
not satisfied by this explanation
and many of them would sue the
government one such court case was perry
versus the united states
john perry who used to own a 10 000 gold
bond argued that he was basically ripped
off by the us
he actually almost won the case as the
final vote was
5-4 but unfortunately the court would
rule that perry had failed to show that
the change in coin weight
had caused them any actual damages the
dissenting opinion was written by
justice james c mcreynolds who called
out the other justices
stating that the court was allowing the
government to ignore the contractual
obligations
for its benefit and honestly this was
the truth
but the supreme court would let it slide
and there was really nothing the victims
could do about it
some would complain about it and i'm
sure many illegally held onto their gold
but sooner or later most people moved on
as you might have noticed though
the u.s actually did nothing to solve
the fundamental issue which was that the
federal reserve was struggling to stick
to the gold reserve ratio
but now that the government had ordered
all the gold in the u.s this wouldn't
become a problem again for a few more
decades
in the meantime the decision to ban gold
ownership seemed like a genius move
after world war ii ended the western
world would adopt the bretton wood
system
which was basically an agreement to keep
world currencies packed to the dollar
and the u.s would give the dollar back
to gold in the beginning
this system worked nearly flawlessly
japan and europe were much more impacted
by world war ii when compared with the
us
so the demand for u.s goods was
extremely high and it made sense to use
a dollar as a standard world currency
moreover the us held 75 percent of the
world's gold reserves
meaning that they had the best backing
for their respective currency
however as the european and japanese
economy started to boom in the 1960s
the demand for u.s dollars decreased as
european and japanese exports became
more competitive
despite this the federal reserve just
continued printing out more
and more money while their gold reserves
weren't really increasing
this eventually led to a situation in
which foreign countries held more u.s
dollars
than the gold the federal reserve held
since the u.s dollar was paid to gold at
per ounce foreign countries technically
had the right to trade in the us dollars
for gold but if every foreign holder was
to go ahead and trade in their cash
the federal reserve would run out of
gold and essentially fail
so the federal reserve was back to
square one they needed more gold to keep
up with their money printing
this time though they couldn't just go
ahead and ban gold worldwide and hoard
all the gold
in the world and so the us would settle
with the only solution they had
which was dropping the gold standard on
august 15 1971
president nixon would announce the us
would no longer exchange dollars for
gold
so i have directed secretary connelly to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar
into gold or other reserve assets
except in amounts and conditions
determined to be in the interest of
monetary stability
and in the best interest of the united
states
soon after inflation would explode as
people didn't trust the us dollar nearly
as much
now that was no longer backed by gold
now that the damage had already been
done
there was no longer a reason for the
federal reserve to try to accumulate all
the gold
in the u.s and on december 31 1974
president ford would sign executive
order 11825 which repealed the executive
order president roosevelt signed 41
years ago
that same day congress would pass
legislation that allowed americans to
own gold
once again and a few years later in 1977
congress would actually revoke the
president's authority to regulate gold
unless the u.s was involved in a war
so looking forward it's highly unlikely
that such a ban on gold will ever happen
again
in the current economic environment the
government simply has no need for that
much gold however
something that the government isn't a
fan of today is bitcoin
bitcoin is promoting a movement towards
a decentralized currency which the
government does not favor for obvious
reasons
considering this great dalio thinks that
the government outlawing bitcoin is
actually a good probability
maybe the next 40-year ban will be on
bitcoin but i guess we'll just have to
wait and see
do you guys think that the us was
justifying the decision to ban gold
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys think that this video
provided a good overview of the gold man
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]
you